[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
quelles sont être très très facile à
utiliser
tout le monde aujourd'hui c'est se
servir d'un micro ondes
on a voulu le rendre encore plus simple
qu'un micro-ondes donc il suffit de
mettre le caddie à l'intérieur de fermer
la porte
d'attendre et tout se fait
automatiquement le cycle est lancée les
uv sont bombarde vraiment littéralement
le caisson nous avons l'équivalent de
plus de deux mille soleils au niveau de
la puissance du vc qui est reçu par le
caddie donc les virus n'ont aucune
chance de s'en sortir
et une fois que le cycle est terminé la
porte s'ouvre automatiquement
il suffit de récupérer le caddie
directement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
on en convient on a on a beaucoup de
mesure donc celle de désinfecter les
caddies aussi après un certain temps
c'est le client qui désinfecte élus
ainsi que kddi et après quelques mois
cela fait beaucoup de déchets et
beaucoup de tâches et on nous a proposé
cette machine on a tout de suite accepté
parce que c'est aussi une meilleure
communication et pour l'avenir on sait
pas ce que ça nous réserve et ses
pratiques de simplement une solution qui
est rapide et très pratique
avant ça il fallait les jours précédents
ont utilisé un spray individuellement
avec un morceau de papier vont se
frotter sur le bord du caddie c'est
beaucoup plus simple comme c'est
maintenant et puis comment on sait très
bien qu'on doit s'inscrire dans dans le
temps avec la gestion du coc vite ce
sera plus facile pour moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]